hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and alissa beak
for easy so I'm a little bit sick right
now I have a lot of body aches I'm very
tired and I'm here because you guys just
won't understand that you'll still
expect a video to be up so here we are
today to watch the trailer for max it's
a story about a war dog
I knew Alyssa would be perfect for this
because Alyssa loves animals she loves
dogs especially I love dogs I really you
know I saw his whole documentary on dogs
they release oxytocin help extend your
life by ten years reduce the risk of
heart disease yeah you know help with
depression a lot of information today
yeah I know it's dude the dogs are
amazing I really want a puppy yeah there
is
most of the dog the harder for marine
sounds like here of me just leave me
after sober you're dealing with a minor
insurgency he's trying to save only
others I thought it was gonna see her
work this morning eight am witness
summer if were they doing here
max bonded so closely with Kyle he can't
work with anyone else are you sure you
want to do this I come over do some
tricks
I'm a bad dog max was this good a dog as
ever passed through this facility
animals can come down with post
traumatic stress
was the best friend that I had
there's something you should stay away
from I'm talking about some bad business
here your brother always wanted to be a
hero so we're gonna read on those cards
dad's a really weird message you
disappeared
we get the Jordan of dogs here
ah it's so close to home
like I got a little emotional for a
second because I've always always had
German shepherds and we just had to put
one of our babies down on Wednesday
so I'm so really sad but um it was great
but she was great but um
dogs man Derek they're the best and like
our other dog that was with us when we
were putting putting her down um his
name is Toby he's he's like my baby I
love him and he is also German Shepherd
and he's also an actor dog he was
actually the star of an Italian TV child
for six years and yeah I had his own
show called okoma sorry Oh Rex
he was Rex is great they're so smart and
so loyal
it's just ridiculous like people they
truly underestimate how amazing these
dogs are we love people all we really
want is like unconditional love and it's
so unreasonable to expect to expect that
from people but with a dog they just
give you that you know they give you
that bond of unconditional love just
like you can be like so loving when them
and then you might get like worked with
them and they'll go oh yeah I get it I
get it and then you give them love and
they're like all right we're back to
love I love that about dogs you know
it's cool that like see like you know
it's a war dog drama yeah to see like
the importance of dog will play in
someone's life when they're out there
you know what sucks is like to the
average person it's gonna sound cheesy
and whatever but this is all just facts
like it's all it's true my brother for
example did not like dogs
what yeah I gave my sister a dog that he
just refused to even pet like he just
didn't like dogs out of nowhere he got
one dog and then within the span of like
a month he got two more dogs like once
you realize just how awesome a dog is
it's not about logic like you just
it you don't want to like get rid of
that feeling I remember like raising a
puppy like that was the most amazing
thing as far as the movie goes on a
technical level there's like I like
everything about it you know like it's
it's interesting to see how important of
a role this dog played to this soldier
and his family yeah and would the main
kid it's kind of his experience of like
grieving and also in a way learning the
bomb with his brother by bonding with
his dog it's kind of a strange message
to it also and other messages don't be a
dick to siblings nope
that's simple that's it what I didn't
really care for in this trailer the last
30 seconds where I was like okay we
didn't need a movie villain takes her to
show up and turn this into like some
intense film all of a sudden I thought
that was really unnecessary I don't I
hope that doesn't get a lot of focus in
the film trailer this is like no ii
totally like an hour and a half two hour
film and totally but you could tell that
when they throw that if they throw that
in there it's gonna seem like i would
have rather just focused on a simple
heartfelt drama not trying to like
suddenly hollywood intensify it that's
all i don't want yeah but then you go
and see this and all of a sudden not
knowing that there is this crazy phil
and all of a sudden you're seeing a
crazy building you're like this isn't
what I signed on for yeah I mean in a
way could work too like we get to see
max kick some ass yeah and like you know
save the day maybe he like bites off
that guy's balls or something then spits
it out into the lake yeah and then the
sequel the balls get discovered by
scientists and they genetically bring
the man back to life where he sets out
on a mission to kill max wait I thought
he was a cyborg at this point because
they couldn't genetically alter him to
be well they took his DNA from his balls
and they were able to make a clone out
of him right the part threes where he's
assigned Cori oh sorry that's okay
it's a trilogy anyway guys thanks for
saying that trailer was out I know a lot
of the female subs wanted that trailer
so that's for you girls that's good see
it I'm gonna say yeah cry like a little
baby any chance you can get Alyssa to
cry on camera take advantage of that
moment this is the first time I've ever
cried on camera for you guys appreciate
it and if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects crazy
sauce over here has a channel to moving
like crazy these days check it out see
what all the craziness is about you
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter and I forgot that we do this
thing called shout outs every once in a
while you know since this is such a
loving episode I wanted to do a shout
out to a guy named Matt the Cookie
Monster Bowman you can check it out on
our Instagram I posted this photo that
he drew his message was I drew this
picture of a Ryan Veronica from the real
rejects I really like y'all's channel
that was where I could get a shout out
to my Instagram Matt to cookie go to
Magda cookie he drew this wonderful
caricature photo of Veronica and I he
kind of Drew me looking like Sylvester
Stallone and Veronica looks like a
Mexican version of the predator really
that's okay don't make that face
I look like I'm stoned but was beaten at
the same time no I'm telling you
Veronica looks like Danny Trejo meets
the predator does but no it's a great
photo and thank you very much man
net